welcome to new gaming network today I'm
going to show you through a DPS last and
build I'm sick of seeing the super
details little videos that can take up
to 20 minutes to watch through so I'm
gonna take to run through this build and
super speedy time covering just the
essentials with a little bit of gameplay
at the end if you're after more detailed
anything just let you know in the
comments below so as I said this is a
DPS last stand Phil to consist of all
high-end gear and Swift towards using
the SMG so the spilled will work well
with assault rifles too however for me
as a console player lovin the SMGs and
an amazing stability right now I'm
running to exotic and for high-end
pieces the exotics consist of skulls in
C club a must for the spells for the
extra sixteen percent damage and short
bone knee pads these are optional birth
would highly recommend farm these
release if you don't have them please
offer a massive bonus and can easily
took the balance without numbered the
high-end pieces include reckless chests
for extra damage tenacious mask for
extra damage specialized backpack as a
skill power top up and a nimble holster
is the only piece of solid healing that
this build has to offer all of these
pieces are then meatheads have been
rolled into firearms and where possible
the major attribute has rolled into
health this includes mods to the weapon
has been given critters damage
everywhere possible and should leave you
sitting with a minimum of forty percent
crit chance and a hundred percent crit
damage or before pulse the building
showing you here isn't then max but
because the last day of normalization
you don't really have to worry about
there the skills own using our scrambler
pulse to block enemy pulses and provide
a normal ten percent increase encrypt
sets charts and damage and booster shot
we get another boost to damage here you
can see how high my dps two bikes are
triggering both tenacious and booster
shot what this builds you need to be
able to play quite reactively if you get
jumped and I prepared you'll get dropped
quick generally you want to be the ones
to start in the battle surprise attacks
will often leave a place please know
what direction your shooter
from
thank you very much for watching this
video as I said earlier the submit to be
a super fast run through of the bill if
more detail is needed or you would like
me to do an extended version of this
build let me know below otherwise if
you've enjoyed this would like to see
more division content please like and
subscribe Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you